so i want to spend just a little bit of
time fact checking
one particular retweet that has been the
source of a lot of controversy from
donald trump's completely unhinged
tweet storm the other day uh and i wanna
really think about this in the context
of the chaos pr
paradigm that we've been discussing the
idea that maybe donald trump benefits
from unrest sort of
either way no matter which side the
unrest is coming from
or whether donald trump actually solves
it
the idea that trump may benefit from it
either way donald trump one of donald
trump's retweets uh
during during his recent tweet storm is
arguably
his most blatant act of racial
incitement
that we've seen and this was a tweet
storm that was triggered right after
a right winger was shot and killed in
portland although donald trump was
remaining very quiet on kyle rittenhouse
the kenosha wisconsin shooter
and within the tweet storm donald trump
retweeted a video
that was originally posted by a user
named i'm with griper which is a right
wing group they've since
changed their name on twitter to try to
seem as though they are associated with
antifa in any case that doesn't really
matter
the video shows a scuffle on a subway
platform
in new york city completely out of
context which ends
when an unidentified black man
pushes a bystander who's a white woman
woman
into a subway car it's completely out of
context
and in fact it happened in 2019 it has
literally nothing to do with what's
going on right now and the unrest
that trump is trying to use to uh
defend or perpetuate his presidency
the retweet has since been deleted
but as you can see uh we still have it
originally from username
tdn noticias which is news
or headlines in spanish and uh
author and former speechwriter for
george w bush david frum commented on
this
calling it quote the most blatant act of
racial incitement in the history of that
office not even andrew johnson
went this far and it is indeed
a completely out of context video this
video of a scuffle
in 2019 on a subway platform
has nothing to do with black lives
matter it has nothing to do with the
protests that are going on
it has nothing to do with george floyd
or kenosha
or portland or anything and in fact if
you research the story
you will find out that this individual
was charged
for shoving this woman on the subway
and there is of course in the widespread
reporting about the incident
no mention whatsoever about an
affiliation with a social movement on
the right or on the left
but this is a perfect example of how any
random video
any random incident any random event
even a picture
is repurposed by white nationalists and
the president then ends up
boosting it now did trump fall for
it was trump tricked here or did he
knowingly retweet something that he knew
was from 2019
it actually doesn't matter because the
goal is just to be a dog whistle the
goal is to amplify
these messages that donald trump
believes are beneficial to him
it's very telling that regularly
his instinct is like put aside the facts
this has not this video this shoving
incident had nothing to do with blm
it wasn't even this year it wasn't even
in the cities trump is talking about
but trump recognized it as a message
or image that was beneficial to him and
it just so happens to be something that
was put out there by white nationalists
and it's because
donald trump has decided stoking racial
tensions is good for me
stoking unrest is good for me creating
racial division is good for me
he may be right and he may be wrong the
calculation
would be it activates more of his people
than biden's people to see this type of
stuff amplified by the president
anybody who opposes black lives matter
in my experience will use anything
any black person has ever done to try to
make their point
even if it has nothing whatsoever to do
with black lives matter
and that's what we're seeing here now
i've gotten a few emails from people
recently saying you know david
you used to be critical of black lives
matter
and now you seem to have fallen in line
have you been
bullied by the left no
uh you are 100 correct that
as an organization i have been critical
of black lives matter in the past and i
maintain every single one of those
criticisms the anti-semitic edge
the disagreement on tactics the belief
that much
of what has been done some of what has
been done is counterproductive to the
cause
but i am not going to fall into the
criticisms
that are wildly racist from the right
about black lives matter and more
importantly
the primary message of black lives
matter is one that i agree with
it's a disagreement on tactics and and
on certain elements of it but
mike the difference is my criticisms
of blm are based on things that have
actually happened
not random videos from 2019 that have
absolutely nothing to do whatsoever with
black lives matter or anything that's
being discussed right now
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and they will pair
you with a mattress that will be perfect
for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video